how are you ma'am okay I'm der oh the
police here you need to come on right
now she looking for where you
at do you know did you see him you know
what he was wearing um yeah that's my oh
God I can't believe this I do not
believe
this um what for a
picture oh my God have
but if we have idea what it was wearing
these guys can go up and check the
parking uh his mom went to the park of
East
went I can't even he wearing black all
black uhhuh and he got on some she
wearing shorts yeah shorts okay um
what's his
[Music]
name uhhuh
Mama should be I don't believe this
wearing a black shirt black shorts uh
that's his mother
right I can't
believe
mother oh my God let me see can I find a
picture over
here I don't believe this I don't know
what the heck is happening around man
when I
moved like this how long ago was the
last person saw him uh the ja the street
gone now five minutes after we uh came
out here looking for him he said he got
in uh uh uh some key folks whatever that
is I don't know what a key boys is
whatever he got in a car that's what I
heard a from my neighbor across the
street he gone now can we get so he got
on a white car
can we get touch with that guy man he in
that car that's what he said he see him
standing right here five minutes he got
in a
car he had gotten a car or
something a white
Kia is here in he's wearing all
black got the white k or something like
that yeah radio that key is just south
of Us in
uh old industrial
lot if he goes up to the right he can't
get out he cannot get out of
there
I'm get a respon
chopper there it
is
dud it's a little kid driving
man radio he can barely see over the
stering
wheel
get
Victory one got a m running Northbound
St light skin great joging
P he's still in the backyard he just
hopped the fence behind the house with
Stevenson one somebody go one Street
East on Stevens
[Applause]
hey I mean this bitch back who the fuck
is that boy who the fuck is you boy
can't drive come here now come here come
here man let police he know this boy
can't drive
oh my God to jail oh my God to jail he
going
God to jail
hey going to
jail hey hey officer officer officer
officer officer I'm going to
jail I'm going to jail
officer I want to jail light skinned
male great jogging pants black and red
shoes I want to jail yes
boy D
that you coming
get I'm going to jail how long I'm be in
there
for officer how long going be in there
for how long going be in there for
officer can I ask you something can I
ask you
something can I ask you
something off he
had he wanted me to drive it he make me
drive it he made me drive it he made me
drive it he made me dve it a back F
offic he made me drive it he made me
drive that's the only only reason he
made me drive it he made me drive it
okay you were driving there yeah he made
me okay hold on Hey listen you're not
going to try to run or anything are
you he try to run or the other guy the
other guy ran passenger hopped
out you're F have a
seat they shaking I mean they went like
at
least did he
crash I did this cuz he he left it he
left it
moving the for how are you ma'am okay
I'm oh the police here you need to come
on right now she looking for where you
at
do you know did you see him you know
what he was wearing uh yeah that's my oh
God I can't believe this I do not
believe
this um what for a
picture oh
my but if we have idea what it was
wearing these guys can go up and check
the parking um his mom and them went to
the park u
e
I can't even he wearing black all black
uhhuh and he got on some she wearing
shorts yeah short okay um what's his
[Music]
name
uhhuh Mama should be okay I don't
believe this wearing a black shirt black
shorts uh that this is
mother I can't
believe
mother oh my God let me see can I find a
picture over
here I don't believe this I don't know
what the heck is happening around here
man when I
moved like this how long ago was last
person s um the Jack Street gone now 5
minutes after we uh came came out here
looking for him he say he got in a uh uh
uh with some key folks whatever that is
I don't know what key boys is whatever
he got in a car that's what I heard from
my neighbor across the street he gone
now can we get he got on a white
car can we get touch with that guy the
man he he in that car that's what he
said he seen him standing right here 5
minutes ago said he got in a car he said
he had got in a car or something
a white
Kia police is here in the house he's
wearing all
black got white Kia or
something yeah radio that key is just
south of us in
uh old industrial
lot if he goes up to the right he can't
get out he cannot get out of
there
ah right
now
I'm not get to respon
Chopper there it
is dude it's a little kid driving
man
radio he can barely see over the
steering
wheel
get vict right one got a m running
Northbound
Stevenson light skin great joging
P he's still in the backyard he just
hopped the fence behind the house of
Stevenson one somebody go one Street
East on
[Applause]
Stevenson I my
hey I mean thisit back who the fuck is
that boy who the fuck is you boy can't
drive come here now come here come here
man let he know this boy can't drive oh
my God want to oh my God I want to ja he
the
godamn
hey I'm going to
jail hey hey officer officer officer
officer officer I'm going to
jail I'm going to jail
officer I'm going to jail light skinned
male great jogging pants black and red
shoes I'm going to jail yes
boy ask driving that car
fucking
you coming to get
me I'm going to jail how long going to
be in there
for officer how long I'm going to be in
there for how long I be in there
for officer can I ask you something can
I ask you
something can I ask you
something oh he had a he wanted me to
drive it he make me drive
it he made me drive it he made me drive
it he made me drive it through a back
fence he made me drive it he made me
drive it that's only only Reas he made
me drive it huh he made me drive it you
were driving there yeah yes he made me
okay hold on made Hey listen you're not
going to try to run or anything are you
did he try to run or was the other guy
the other guy ran
passenger hopped out seat right here
you're fine have a seat
okay shaking you're shaking I mean they
went like at
least did he
crash I did this cuz he he left itun he
left it
moving
sure yeah